looks like what about 9 billion dollars
it could be faced with in terms of minds
right it is said to plan a guilty plea
in a settlement of these charges and
indeed would pay a penalty of almost
nine billion dollars also would be
barred from clearing US dollar
transactions u.s. dollars i should say
for as long as a year this according to
a person familiar with the negotiations
here so it looks like what is now clear
and has been confirmed is that it's
being charged in this criminal probe of
US sanctions violations people with a
familiar with the situation are talking
to us about the settlement the amount
that might be involved and the penalties
that may be involved for background here
the company according to these peoples
agreed to plead guilty for processing
funds involving Sudan Iran Cuba and a
suspected of hiding almost thirty
billion dollars worth of transactions
related to those countries as we know
we've been talking a lot about US
authorities have been getting more
aggressive in trying to prosecute of
these various banks that have been
alleged to be involved in these types of
transactions the investigation though
has been going on for seven years so
these are now coming to a conclusion but
again here BNP paribas now been formally
charged in a criminal probe of US
sanctions violations and people familiar
with its plans are saying that it has
agreed to plead guilty be barred from US
dollar a clearing for a year and to pay
nine billion dollars in penalties